the opening scene features thousands of
soldiers led by the prince of the D
Nation they surround the city of the
Southern Song Dynasty and launch an
attack on the city walls instead of
using pounding weapons to breach the
gates the D Army opts to catapult
soldiers into the city the flying
soldiers then open the gates except for
the ones who broke their pelvises
allowing the other troops to enter the
city and wreak havoc the song Army led
by General Wayan Chuan tries to fend off
the enemy but they soon find themselves
overwhelmed by Superior numbers at this
critical point a man named Jiang junbao
appears and showcases his exceptional
Marshal prowess when confronting the D
tribes in this battle he's backed up by
his wui sect mate named Shee who also
exhibits formidable combat abilities
despite her young age with the help of
the duo the Song Dynasty are slowly able
to turn the tables around amidst of the
ongoing conflict a female Warrior from
the dribe engaged engages in a duel with
General Chuan witnessing the general
struggling to fight her Jun ba decides
to intervene and assist him however the
female Warrior abruptly Retreats
expressing her disinterest in fighting
him unbeknownst to the song forces her
actual mission was to secure a
particular item after successfully
obtaining it she promptly delivers it to
the prince of the dribe it turns out to
be a key that can break the seal Bing
the demon sect Master just then the D
soldiers station within the city alert
them of a powerful Arrow launched by the
Song Dynasty the arrow narrowly misses
its intended target Prince D and instead
strikes their flag seeing this the
female Warrior advises the prince to
retreat asserting that they've got what
they wanted the ladder obliges and
orders a swift Retreat for all of his
troops in the meantime two enemy
soldiers abduct sheim May and take her
along with them as her cries reach
juna's ears he quickly mounts a horse
and pursues the kidnapper ERS into the
Forbidden territory of the insect Valley
upon entering the forest the enemies
encounter an unusual occurrence their
horses suddenly come to a halt and react
with fear throwing the Riders to the
ground in an unexpected turn of events
the ground beneath them begins to
crumble and one of the soldiers is
pulled into the surface not long after a
giant silkor worm emerges from behind
and kills a soldier it then lunges
towards shim but Jun ba arrives in the
nick of time and rescues her he then
prepares to confront the massive worm
when suddenly a mysterious woman appears
out of nowhere and soothes the creature
with a flute this woman named uur
initially mistakes Jun ba for a dribe
member but he quickly clarifies the
matter he also explains the reason why
he entered this forbidden area hearing
this the woman lets them go but not
before warning them to stay clear of the
area her threat is very intimidating
because of of the flute on the other
hand General Chuan pays a visit to a
city official seeking information about
potential reinforcements the official
casually dismisses his concern claiming
that there's no hope of reinforcements
the general then tries to convey the
dire circumstances of the war but the
official brushes him off helpless
General Chuan departs feeling stressed
about how to protect his country later
on Jun ba returns and invites General
Chuan to join him for a drink the two of
them are revealed to be childhood
friends now that he knows about Jun Ba's
Martial Arts Press General Chuan
attempts to convince him to fight for
the nation however Juneau replies that
saving the country is the General's
responsibility while he as an ordinary
man prefers to indulge in Simple
Pleasures like eating drinking and
making pills of
immortality what was that third one in
the next scene Jun ba visits an elderly
man who has been incarcerated for 12
years this man turns out to be a
formidable enemy of the wui sect and the
one whom Prince D wants to release he is
the master of the demon sect qu tan
Shing it appears that Juneau regularly
visits the old man and offers him wine
in exchange for knowledge of the demon
sect's fighting techniques despite the
wuji sect's prohibition on learning
these moves junb doesn't care with the
sect leader selection day approaching he
plans to master the techniques and
defeat other candidates the scene then
fast forwards to the selection day and a
candidate named and Fang is seen
defeating his opponents one after
another as he is about to secure the
victory Jun walks in and challenges him
for the fight he uses the demon sect's
moves which are considered Evil by the
wui sect and defeats man Fang however
the crowd disapproves of this leading
the master to denounce Juneau and warn
him against learning such techniques
Juna defends himself arguing that
martial arts techniques are not
inherently good or evil it's the user's
intention that matters and every
American in the Deep South will make the
same argument about their guns this
argument brings the competition to a
halt and after everyone exits the room
Juna realizes that the key to the prison
has disappeared this freaks him out so
he quickly heads out from there
meanwhile at the demon sect headquarters
Ur the daughter of Tian Shing becomes
incensed upon learning that her sect
members have been covertly collaborating
with the dribe they're secretly
strengthening their position to launch
an attack on their other rival eight
sect shortly after Prince D shows up and
seeks cooperation to destroy the wuji
sect in exchange for the key to release
her father however Ur firmly rejects
their proposal enraging the prince as a
result one of his men attacks her with a
powerful blow injuring her badly she is
then warned that the poison she's been
Afflicted with can kill her in 3 days
despite her critical condition none of
her fellow sect members dare to step
into her Aid knowing that she can't
confront them in her weakened State she
flees the scene the next day Jun ba
takes a leisurely stroll in the forest
when the giant silkworm unexpectedly
appears grabs his wine bottle and
wanders off thanks for the booze
while searching for his bottle Jun ba
comes across the injured uur who is
leaning against a bamboo tree and the
effect of the poison seems to be
spreading through her body thankfully
Jun ba has his immortality pills with
him which he gives to her he then uses a
bamboo stick to extract the the poison
from her body his treatment proves
effective for Ur as the scar quickly
disappears from her body later in the
evening the combined forces of the dribe
and the demon sect mount an attack on
the wui sect headquarters sadly there's
no one capable of stopping The Intruders
so it becomes easy for them to
accomplish their mission of releasing
tition Shing once the demon sect Master
is free he effortlessly eliminates all
the wuji sect members on the other hand
Jun B pract practices some Marshall
moves while waiting for Ur to regain
Consciousness when she finally wakes up
she expresses her gratitude to him she
also asks how she can repay him and in
response junb playfully suggests a drink
their conversation is interrupted by the
sudden arrival of sheim who informs him
about the attack on their base alarmed
the group hurries to the base but it's
too late as all the sect members are
dead just then tion Shing and his
followers appear and tell them to meet
their master in the prison the female
Warrior from the dribe then Returns the
key to Jun ba before they all depart
later Jun ba and sheim may quickly head
to the prison only to find their Master
teetering on the brink of death he
entrusts Juneau with the league Master
token stating that they the last
remaining Heirs of the wuji sect he also
advises them to uphold righteousness in
their lives before finally passing away
the days then pass by but junb is unable
to move past the tragic event he blames
himself for the entire thing one night
while uur plays her flute in the forest
she's approached by her father he urges
her to return to the sect with him but
she declines she reveals that the sect
members have formed an alliance with the
dribe and she suspects they intend to
use her father's power to conquer the
Marshal realm nevertheless tition Shing
appears to be unaffected turns out that
he Harbors a deep grudge against the
entire Kingdom especially the E sect
which had sought to take down the demon
insect in the past it was during that
time that her wife sacrificed herself to
protect Ur following this Tian Shing
returns to the demon sect headquarters
where he punishes the members for
allying with the dribe and endangering
his daughter's life however his speech
is cut short by the arrival of a dribe
representative with a mask who asks him
to collaborate with them to eliminate
the eight sect tition Shing refuses to
do so and asserts that he'll exact his
revenge independently the representative
claims that he owes them a favor so he
can't turn them down in a fit of rage
tition Shing hurls a sword towards the
representative but the masked man is
powerful enough to bend it easily in the
next scene Jun ba visits the E sect to
team up and eliminate the dribe he
firstly greets the tribe members but
there's no response suddenly a powerful
gust of wind sweeps through causing them
to fall it turns out that all eight
members of the sect have been killed by
tion Shing moments later the demon sect
Master appears in front of jun ba fueled
by anger he attacks tition Shing
triggering a fierce battle between the
two however he is quickly overpowered by
his much more formidable enemy as Jun ba
is about to get defeated uur intervenes
and informs her father that he was the
one who saved her life earlier this
Revelation prompts ton Shing to spare
Jun Bal but he gives him a warning that
if he touches his daughter's butt he'll
kill him twice however before they
depart the same masked man blocks their
path this kicks off another fight
between Tian Shang and the masked man
after a short while the demon sect
Master finds himself on the losing end
of the battle prompting Jun ba to step
in and defend him amidst the ongoing
combat junb manages to remove the Man's
mask revealing that he's none other than
General Chuan here it's revealed that
General Chuan was the one who stole the
key from him and collaborated with the D
tribe he did all this due to his
frustration with corrupt officials a
real Kung Fu Serpico after this
Revelation General Chuan still gives
junb a chance to become his partner and
conquer the world together however Juna
stays true to his morals and turns down
the offer in response to this rejection
General Chuan proceeds to finish him off
but at the same time shim intervenes
they fight for a while but the powerful
General eventually defeats and poisons
her knowing that they can't over power
the general tan Shing summons the giant
silkworm to take away junbao she may and
his daughter he then uses the rest of
his strength to earn them some time to
flee however because of this selfless
act he ends up getting killed at the
hands of the general meanwhile the giant
silkworm transports the group to the
forest you got any more of that booze
where she may succumbs to the poison
this breaks Jun ba and he once again
starts blaming himself the following day
he is suddenly ambushed by two members
of the demon sect they ruthlessly attack
him until he loses Consciousness and
falls into a nearby lake while drowning
junb reflects on the teachings of the
sect leaders yuur Tian Shing and general
Chuan these Recollections Inspire him to
persevere for goodness at the same time
a couple of fish surround him enabling
him to perform his martial arts skills
he then eventually gains Mastery over
his techniques underwater empowered with
these Newfound taiichi skills and Having
learned them faster than a shenmue game
Juna effortlessly overpowers the two
enemies and defeats them meanwhile at
the dribe headquarters Prince D Praises
General Chuan for successfully defeating
the eth sect he then shares his plan to
attack the central plains the following
day and appoints General Chuan as the
chief military commander however the
latter has something else in mind so he
refuses to serve the prince any longer
after this he eliminates all the dribe
members one after another while he goes
after the prince uur intervenes and
engages in a battle with him shortly
after junb also shows up and urges his
childhood friend to choose the path of
righteousness however General Chuan who
has experienced numerous betrayals from
the world rejects the offer this leads
to a fierce duel between them as the
fight intensifies the giant silkworm
appears in support of UR and junb the
creature ejects white silky balls from
his mouth suck on this boys in snaring
both the men with its strands General
Chuan is AED by the silkor worm's
incredible power so he tears through the
silk ball ascends the top of the
creature and plucks out its heart he
believes that eating its heart will
further increase his strength jokes on
you that's my kidney stone just then a
large Rock Falls from above hitting both
junb and general Chuan and rendering
them unconscious for some time upon
waking up they resume their battle until
General Chuan is poisoned by the silk
worm's heart ultimately resulting in his
death in the final scene we see junb and
uur parting their ways forever Ur
embarks in search of a beautiful place
free from conflict while Jun ba decides
to embrace the present moment leaving
the past behind and making the most of
whatever life may bring his way
subscribe for more videos like this turn
on notifications and leave a like to
help the channel out thank you for
watching